la actualidad más destacada del
continente africano en france24 esto es
áfrica siete días comenzamos con los
titulares los votantes senegaleses
fueron convocados para elegir a sus
diputados en unas elecciones
consideradas como una prueba para el
presidente macky sall nuestra
corresponsal en dakar nos explica lo que
está en juego
la situación política en áfrica
occidental ha cambiado en los últimos
años y francia perdió influencia en la
región el presidente francés emmanuel
marco estuvo de gira por áfrica en un
intento de redefinir los contornos de su
relación con el continente tenemos
análisis del tema y hablamos de la
victoria del presidente tunecino país
ayer su controvertida constitución fue
aprobada por una amplia mayoría en un
referéndum que contó con poca
participación ciudadana y que fue
rechazado por la oposición el nuevo
texto otorga amplitud de poderes al
presidente
unos siete millones de senegaleses
fueron convocados a las urnas para unos
comicios parlamentarios unas elecciones
que pretenden renovar los 165 escaños
del legislativo que está hasta ahora
controlado en gran medida por el bando
presidencial
nuestra corresponsal en dakar
ccoo nos explica por qué estas
elecciones legislativas son cruciales
para ese país la votación del domingo se
desarrolló con calma sin ningún
incidente digno de mención sólo uno de
cada cinco votantes fue a las urnas
según una estimación provisional
publicada el mismo día esas elecciones
son muy importantes en el contexto
político actual se consideran un poco
como un referéndum a favor o en contra
del poder un ensayo general antes de las
elecciones presidenciales de 2024 porque
hay que entender que el presidente macky
sall debe dejar el poder en 2024 pero la
oposición lo acusa de querer presentarse
a un 3er está prohibido por la
constitución él mantiene la
incertidumbre sobre sus intenciones
entonces si su partido obtiene la
mayoría en esas elecciones
podrías decidir seguir con este proyecto
al contrario si gana la oposición el
campo presidencial lo abandonará guía
entonces según los analistas los
resultados de esas elecciones pueden
cambiar el futuro político del país más
concretamente los senegaleses también
esperan mucho de este sufragio para
mejorar su vida cotidiana quieren que
los parlamentarios arreglen el problema
del coste de la vida y los jóvenes
quieren sobre todo trabajo representan
que hacia el 30% de los votantes por lo
tanto su voz es decisiva
en los últimos años francia ha perdido
influencia en sus antiguas colonias y
territorios de áfrica occidental por los
distintos cambios políticos que se han
dado en la región en este contexto el
presidente de francia emmanuel mckeown
visitó camerún bening y guinea bissau
para analizar este tema estamos en
contacto con jagger bagayoko politóloga
y presidenta del africano securities
texture network y esta es su opinión
con inquina de manuel mac con los
primeros cinco años del mandato de
manuel marco se han caracterizado por un
preocupante deterioro de la imagen de
francia en el continente africano
si sólo con si no aplicamos al original
desde el diversión en el origen de este
deterioro de la percepción de francia
entre la opinión pública africana y en
particular de áfrica occidental se
encuentra la intervención francesa en el
sahel y en particular en madre
un doble resultado no sea no cuyos
resultados no han respondido claramente
a las expectativas creadas existe se
topea y se pelean son buscan el avión y
hip hop childe facilitó el objetivo de
esta operación denominada 'operación
marcando era erradicar a los cada vez
más influyentes grupos yihadistas cuya
influencia se ha ido extendiendo desde
2012 primero desde el norte de mali
luego desde el centro de malo después
desde el oeste de mi el norte y el este
de burkina faso y ahora a los países
costeros del golfo de guinea y conchi
rudy un software que les opinión hoy en
día podemos ver que la opinión pública
africana pero también ciertos gobiernos
en particular el de malí ahora está
controlado por los militares que tomaron
el poder en agosto de 2020 tienen una
imagen particularmente degradada de
francia a la que atacan por considerar
que es la fuente de muchos de los
problemas que les afectan
desde el punto de vista de la seguridad
sino también más ampliamente desde el
punto de vista económico o político
queda por ver ahora si las iniciativas
del presidente francés darán sus frutos
según la experta francia tiene que
aceptar un tablero donde ya no es la
principal potencia extranjera con
influencia en la región y actuar en
consecuencia
de africa rugby todos los estados
africanos se encuentran hoy en día en
una posición en la que buscan afirmar
aún más sus prerrogativas en su
soberanía y también diversificar sus
asociaciones
han activa habla mucho del papel de
rusia en la actualidad ya no es un nuevo
actor al contrario de lo que se oye me
fue ejercicio tradicional sobre todo en
términos de seguridad durante la guerra
fría que está renovando sus alianzas
pero también hay socios como turquía por
ejemplo que se está convirtiendo en un
actor importante desde el punto de vista
mental en términos de asociación en el
continente
así pues hoy será necesario que francia
cumpla con tres obligaciones por un lado
aceptar formar parte de esta
diversificación de asociaciones que
todos los líderes africanos reclaman en
segundo lugar responder de forma mucho
más humilde a las expectativas de la
opinión pública y en tercer lugar
adoptar una postura mucho más discreta y
asegurarse de que comunicación no sea
contraproducente como lo ha sido en los
últimos cinco años la negación de su
abajo colectiva así que la ley de ojos
de sam granjas de nec pacífico
en túnez una nueva constitución
propuesta por el presidente caisse side
fue aprobada con esta nueva carta magna
el presidente gozará de poderes mucho
más amplios y prácticamente sin rendir
cuentas a alguien de este modo se da una
ruptura con la constitución de 2014
surgida tras la revolución tunecina
enero de 2014 tres años después de la
revolución tunecina los diputados acaban
de aprobar una constitución que marcaría
el inicio de una nueva era política para
el país la nueva ley fundamental
consagraba un régimen parlamentario y
daba un lugar reducido al islám
[Música]
un momento histórico de orgullo se ven
las expresiones de alegría de orgullo de
reconocimiento a todos los que
contribuyeron a este momento
ocho años después el presidente tunecino
caixa 7 culpa a esta constitución de los
males del país sumido en una crisis
socioeconómica extrema por ello ayer
decidió proponer una nueva constitución
profundamente diferente de la anterior
el mandatario seleccionó a los miembros
de la comisión encargada de redactar el
texto antes de elegir finalmente una
versión personal alejada de la propuesta
que se había preparado además de reducir
el papel del parlamento el nuevo texto
convierte los tres poderes en simples
funciones
si hoy se establece un régimen de
confusión de poderes como es el caso del
proyecto de constitución el presidente
monopolizar a todo el abanico de poderes
así la garantía de las libertades se
desaparece hay una amenaza para las
libertades para mí esto es el resumen de
una mala constitución además es una
constitución que fue escrita por una
sola persona
otro de los puntos más debatidos se
refiere al lugar que ocupa el islam el
artículo 5 afirma que túnez forma parte
de la oma islámica dentro de un sistema
democrático y que sólo el estado debe
garantizar los objetivos del islam una
disposición criticada por los defensores
de una clara separación entre religión y
estado
35% de los votantes registrados
participaron en la consulta mientras que
el sí obtuvo el 94 6% de los votos si la
oposición teme que se vuelva a un
régimen autocrático el presidente cuenta
todavía con una importante base de apoyo
popular basada principalmente en la
esperanza de que mejore la situación
socioeconómica y en el rechazo a los
partidos asociados a la administración
posterior a la revolución
cambiamos ahora de tema y vamos a
marruecos a lo largo de las dos últimas
décadas la ong human rights watch ha
documentado las constantes acusaciones y
persecuciones a periodistas en este país
un reciente informe evidencia el aumento
de casos en los últimos años para hablar
sobre este tema conversamos con sofía
catalán nuestra corresponsal en
marruecos
si te atraparán hagas lo que hagas es el
título del demoledor informe de human
right watch es sobre la persecución
contra activistas y periodistas aquí en
marruecos se trata de una investigación
de dos años plasmada en un informe de
129 páginas en el que documentan hechos
muy graves denuncian campañas de
difamación
espionaje juicios y veredictos injustos
dicen basados en la instrumentalización
de delitos sexuales y la intimidación de
testigos así como violencia física y
también acoso a las familias de los
disidentes con esto human righs watch
acusa al estado marroquí y de crear
dicen un sofisticado modus operandi para
callar las voces hay críticas y también
les acusan dicen de proyectar una falsa
imagen a nivel internacional de
moderación y progreso en cuanto cuando
en realidad la situación en derechos y
libertades aquí en el país es cada vez
peor lo cierto es que marruecos es cada
vez más difícil informar sobre todo para
los periodistas marroquíes
independientes a sonados son los casos
de omar y souleymane raisuni periodistas
críticos encarcelados por delitos
sexuales que no pudieron llegar a
probarse en lo que ya es un patrón que
no deja de repetirse
hace unas semanas anunciamos el inicio
de la copa africana de naciones femenina
y les presentamos a las mejores
jugadoras del continente el 23 de julio
el torneo llegó a su fin en una
emocionante final disputada entre
marruecos y la selección sudafricana de
fútbol esta última se impuso por primera
vez en su historia 2 a 1 ante las
marroquíes con las imágenes de
recibimiento en casa de las nuevas
campeonas de la copa africana de
naciones nos despedimos gracias por
acompañarnos y la información sigue en
francés y 4 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]